نعلن عن وفاه
الاخ عفاف ياسر زايد
عفوا الاخت عفاف ياسر زايد ام يعقوب من
بيتونيا فلسطين صلاه الجنازه بكره الخميس
بعد الظهر والدفن في العزاء من الاربعه
للسته في الاقصى كما نعلن عن وفاه الدكتور
غازي صالح النهار
بني ملحم من قريه
من اربد الاردن
صلاه الجنازه بكره بعد الظهر والدفن فيه
والعزاء من السبعه للعشره في قاعه ترمس
عيا غفر الله لنا ولهما ولموت المسلمين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
يقول الله تعالى
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا يسخر قوم من قوم
عسى ان يكونوا خيرا منهم
ولا نساء من نساء عسى ان يكن خيرا منهن
ولا تلمزوا انفسكم يعني لا تعيبوا
انفسكم يعني بعض لا يعب بعضكم بعضا
ولا تنابزوا بالالقاب
والمقصود بالالقاب هنا
ولقب الذي
يراد منه الاهانه الذي يراد منه
الحق من قدر الملقب
او يكون بغير رضا
الملقب
مهما يكون
مهما كان اللقب فانه يشترط فيه رضا
الملقب اذا لم يرضى فانه لا يجوز هذا هو
الاصل
يقول بئس بئس الاسم الفسوق بعد الايمان
ومن لم يتوب فاولئك هم الظالمون
قوله تعالى بئس الاسم
هذه جمله كامله مفيده
بئس الاسم
والله عز وجل يشير
باللام الاسم
هذه تسمى بلام
العهد الذكري
يعني هذا اللقب
فانه
بئس الاسم
يعني شر الاسماء
هذا يكون
وقوله تعالى
بئس الاسم الفسوق
كلمه الفسوق
هذه تسمى عند علماء النحو بالبدل
ايش يعني البدل
ننظر الى المبدل منه وهو كلمه الاسم
عشان نفهم البدل
نقيم كلمه الاسم وبنحط محله الفسوق
هذا المعنى البدل
فيصير المعنى
بئس الاسم
وبالبدل بئس الفسوق
ايش فائده البدل
فائده البدل
انها
او فائده البدل ان البدل يقوم مقام جملتين
او ثلاثه
ما نعيد ونزيد ونزيد في الجمل
ياتي المتكلم بالبدل
والمبدل منه
فيتم المعنى
ويستقيم في ذهن السامع
دون ان نزيد في عدد الجمل
استقل
هذا البدل
بمعنيين وقام مقام ثلاث جمل
فقوله تعالى بئس الاسم يعني هذا هذا اللقب
الذي
تتنابزون به
فهذا بئس الاسم بعد الايمان
بعد ان كان هذا مؤمنا ثم يطلق عليه من
الالقاب ما لا يليق بالمؤمن
فهذا في الجاهليه مثلا هذا في الجاهليه
اطلق عليه لقب ما يعني لقب يشعر بالاهانه
خلينا نقول يطلق عليه
رديء
في الجاهليه ثم اسلم وامن
وبعد ذلك برضو لقبه الرديء كيف هذا
بئس الاسم بعد الايمان هذا امن الان اختلف
الامر
وايضا
فقوله تعالى بئس الاسم يعني بئس الفسوق
بعد الايمان
للذي يلقب غيره بهذه الالقاب هذا فسق
وهذا الفسوق
بئس الفسوق بعد الايمان تكنت مؤمن ثم خرجت
عن الايمان المعتدل الى الفسوق حينما لقبت
اخاك
ونبذته
بلقب لا يرضاه الله
فاصبحت فاسقا بعد الايمان
ففهمنا من هذا
ان هذه الافعال
ان يسخر قوم من قوم
او نساء من نساء
او ان يلمز بعضنا بعض
او ان نتنابز بالالقاب فان هذا كله فسوق
عند الله سبحانه وتعالى
ايش يعني فسوق
معنى فسوق
انه خروج عن الايمان الواجب
فهو
كبيره من كبائر الذنوب
لا يسقطه
العمل الصالح
ولا يسقطه الا التوبه النصوح
والانتزاع عن هذا العمل
لذلك ختم الله هذه الايه بالتوبه قال ومن
لم يتب فاولئك هم الظالمون
ففهمنا ان التوبه
هي الوحيده التي يمحو الله سبحانه وتعالى
بها هذا الفسوق
فقول الله تعالى بئس الاسم الفسوق بعد
الايمان فهمنا من هذا
انه يقول
بئس الاسم بعد الايمان يعني
هذا اللقب او هذا الاستصخار او ما شابه
ذلك هذا بئس ما يكون ان تسمي به مؤمنا ثم
بئس الفسوق بعد الايمان
يعني ان الذي يفعل هذا فانه قد اصبح فاسقا
بعد ان كان مؤمنا وهذا الفسوق
بئس الفسوق لانه فسوق كان بعد الايمان
والفسوق الذي يكون قبل الايمان وقبل ان
يعلم الانسان الكتاب والايمان ويعلم ما
يرضي الله
وما يسخط الله فان هذا فسوق لكن اشد
الفسوق ما كان بعد الايمان بعد ان تتم هذه
المعلومات ثم يختار العصيان والعنا على
الهدى فان هذا بئس الفسوق
وقوله تعالى
بئس الاسم الفسوق بعد الايمان
انه من فعل هذا فانه اصبح فاسقا واصبح
مرتكبا لكبير من كبائر الذنوب
يقول تعالى ومن لم يتب فاولئك هم الظالمون
الذي لا يتوب من هذه الاعمال
الذي لا يتوب من امثال هذه الامور
فانه لن يزال ظالما حتى يتوب حتى ينزع
والذي يمتنع عن التوبه فقد اضاف الفسوق
الى الظلم
وفهمنا من هذا ان هذه الامور التي ذكرها
الله سبحانه وتعالى واعدها فانها من الظلم
من الاعتداء والغط من حقوق الاخرين
لكن هذه الامور التي ذكرها الله هل هي
كبيره
هي كبيره عند الله لكن عند الناس
لا شيء
ما هي
سليمات تكلموا بها المتكلم
وانما هي امور دارجه
بين الناس
والناس من كثر ما يصنعون هذا الصنيع
فان الذي يغضب من هذا
يعني اذا استسخر من احد فغضب او اذا اخذ
على باله لانه حدا نبذه بلقب ولا لحد
فهذا هو الظالم عند الناس
لماذا كيف لا نحن بنمزح معك مالك فلان
هدي من روعك قصه مش هيك يا فلان
لكن عند الله سبحانه وتعالى
فان هذه امور عظيمه عظيمه
ثم ناس
يقولون لا اله الا الله
سيدخلون النار
في يوم القيامه
يعذبون بها من جراء هذه الامور
هل هي صغيره ولا كبيره يعني ثم ناس وناس
ياتون يوم القيامه بالصلاه والصيام
واعظم ما ياتي به احدنا يوم القيامه وهو
قول لا اله الا الله
ثم بعد ذلك
يدخل النار ويعذب في نيران جهنم لماذا
من جراء هذه الامور التي ذكرها الله ونهى
عنها هل هي كبيره او صغيره هينا عند الناس
لكنها عند الله
عظيمه هذا الذي يهمنا
المؤمن
مؤمن لا يهمه غفله الناس
لا يهمه
طغيان الناس او انحراف الناس لو انحرف
جميع من في الارض
فان هذا لا يساوي عنده كلمه يقولها الله
المؤمن ينظر الى ما
جعله الله عظيما فيعظمه والى ما حقره الله
فيستحقره هذا هو المؤمن
لان الموازين موازين الله
ولان
العظيم معظمه الله
والحقير مستحقره الله سبحانه وتعالى
هذه امور
ايسر من كل يسير
يعني تصور الواحد عشان يصلي
او عشان يحج
بده يحوش مصاري وبده يتعب وبده يجيب من
ياخذه على الحج وبده يجهز حاله وبده يتاهب
وبده يحمل حاله ويروح الحاج وبده يطوف في
الكعبه ويكون في غربه والى اخره ثم بعد
ذلك
ينبز هذا بلقب
ويغتاب هذا ويهين هذا ويعتدي على هذا
فياتي يوم القيامه ويدخل النار ما رايكم
ان هذا شيء عجاب امر عجيب جدا
انسان
سعى في مرضات الله
ولكنه لم يسعى
في الانتهاء عن مناهي الله ولم يعظم ما
عظمه الله
فلم يتعلم في الدنيا فعلمه الله في الاخره
نسال الله العافيه
هذه مساله عظيمه عند عند الله
والانسان يعظم ما عظمه الله
ولا يهمه
تعظيم الناس او تحقير الناس
لشيء ما يقول الله تعالى في مساله هينا
عند الناس اهون ما تكون عند الناس وذلك
البهتان
ان يبهت
انسان انسان انسانا فش اسهل منها عند
الناس
فيقول تعالى وتحسبونه هينا وهو عند الله
عظيم حد في ظهور بعض الناس ورد شهاده الى
يوم القيامه
وتبرئه اخرين
وقد يقع في هذا رجم حتى الموت وقد يكون
الجلد
والتغريب وهكذا مساله عظيمه عظمها الله
سبحانه وتعالى وهي عند الناس فش اسهل منها
فان الانسان
كما قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم عرضه
لهافوات
وكبوات لسانه
لذلك جاء في الحديث الذي في الصحيحين اذا
اصبح الانسان
فان جميع الجوارح تكفر اللسان وتقول انما
نحن بك
انما نحن بك
اعتدلت جوارحه ولسانه لم يعتدل فدخلوا
اجمعين النار
من اجل اللسان انما نحن بك
هكذا جاء في الحديث في الحديث الاخر
ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
قد يتكلم
المتكلم بالكلمه من رضوان الله تعالى لا
يلقي لهذه الكلمه بالا
ويدخل بسبب الجنه
وفي المقابل
قد يتكلم بالكلمه من سخط الله ومن غضب
الله لا يلقي لهذه الكلمه بالا ولا يتثبت
فيها
ويهوي بها في النار
سبعين خريفا
سبعين سنه وهو يهوى في النار والعياذ
بالله من كلمه قالها
اجت راحت
والعياذ بالله
فهنا يقول بئس الاسم الفسوق بعد الايمان
هذه الاشياء التي ذكرناها
هذه الامور
التنابز بالالقاب والاستسخار
ولمس
اخرين
والتنابز بالالقاب
وعدم التثبت كل ما سبق في الصوره وكل ما
سبق في هذه الايه خاصه
نظرنا الى هذه الامور
وجدنا ان هذه الامور
كلها من الفسوق
وهذه الامور قد جمعها النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم في مقوله واحده قال في البخاري ومسلم
حديث عبد الله قال
في باب المسلم فسوق وقتاله كفر كلمه سب
السباب
هذه الكلمه تجمع جميع هذه المنهيات
كل اعتداء يكون باللسان على الاخر فانه
يعتبر سبا السب في لغه العرب هو ماذا الحظ
من قدر الغير
وكل كلمه يتكلم بها
ويقصد بهذه الكلمه
الحط من قدر الغير هذا اسمه سب في لغه
العرب
ولذلك
يقول تعالى
ولا تسبوا الذين يدعون من دون الله
يعني اللات والعزه ومنات وهؤلاء هذه
الالهه التي تعبد من دون الله شلون
المؤمنون يسبونها يسبونها يعني يقولون هذه
لا تنفع ولا تضر ماذا يقصدون بهذه الكلمه
الحط من قدرها التي
قدرها عابدوها
فنهى الله سبحانه وتعالى عن ذلك هذا هو
السب في لغه العرب
هذا السب
اذا
توجه الى مسلم فانه فسوق في كتاب الله ايش
يعني فسوق يعني كبيره من كبائر الذنوب
هذا الان لا يطلق عليه
مؤمن هكذا باطلاق وانما يقال هذا مؤمن
فاسق هكذا
ان الله عز وجل قال بئس الاسم الفسوق بعد
الايمان بعد ان كان يقال هذا مؤمن الان
يقال هذا فاسق
بان الايمان المطلق لا ينطبق عليه هذا
عنده فسوق الان
ليس انه يدخل النار ابدا لا
ولكن معناه انه مطلق الايمان ليس عنده
الان
هذا ناقص الايمان فاسق هذا معنى الفاسق
الفاسق ضد المؤمن المؤمن هو كامل للايمان
والفاسق هو ناقص الايمان
فهذا فاسق
ووصفه الله تعالى بالفسوق لان الفسوق كما
ذكرنا هو
الحل عن الشيء بعد ان كان
مستجمعا عليه
فاذا نظرنا الى شيء مربوط مثلا
حليناه
فهذا يقال له فسق في لغه العرب
فهذا كان
مؤمنا
وكان مستجمعا امره على طاعه الله ثم ماذا
كان جاء الفسوق فانحل عن امر الله سبحانه
وتعالى فاصبح فاسقا بعد ان كان مؤمنا
فيقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم سباب
المسلم الفسوق لو كان يسمع وانت بتسب فهذا
اسمه ماذا هذا هذا اسمه سب
وايضا اذا كان ما يسمع فانت اغتبته هذا
اسمه سب في لغه العرب واذا ناديت بنداء
تريد ان تهينه او تحط من قدره فهذا اسمه
سب
واذا طعنت فيه شيء
يلحق به
فهذا اسم سب
واذا غمزت
غمزت لصاحبك هيك وهو واقف يعني يشوف
ها فهذا اسمه ايش هذا اسمه سب
فهذا الذي يصنع هذا اصبح ماذا فاسقا
معقوله معقوله يا شيخ انه الواحد يحرك
عينه يصبح فاسق ايوه نعم لان الحركه مش
المقصد
يعني هذا مثل واحد يقتل واحد
وقول انا انما حركت اصبعي بس
حركته اصبعك لكن ماذا صنع هذا الاصبع لما
عرقته
هذا لا يهمنا حركت اصبعك ولا كل جسمك
الذي يهمنا النتيجه ايش النتيجه احزنت
المؤمن
والحقت به ما لم يلحق به ربنا سبحانه
وتعالى
وكل هذه الاشياء لانك غمزت عينك وما عرفت
تدافع
وتقاتل نفسك وشيطانك هذا الذي حصل
فهذا كله يسمى في لغه العرب سبا هذا كله
سب
وهذا السب فسوق
فاي اعتداء من مؤمن
او اي اعتداء على مؤمن باللسان
او بالقول فانه فسوق قال وقتاله كفر اي
اعتداء على المسلم
باليد فان هذا يسمى ماذا
يسمى كفرا عند الله
هكذا الحديث سباب المسلم فسوق
وقتاله كفر
اسال الله سبحانه وتعالى العفو والعافيه
وان يصلح شاننا ما ظهر منه وما بطن والله
اعلم صلى الله عليه وسلم على نبينا محمد